desde que el ejército tomó el poder el 1
de febrero nadie había visto aún san suu
kyi la líder elegida democráticamente en
mianmar ahora uno de sus abogados tiene
buenas noticias si ella pidió y exigió
una reunión privada como abogada y
acusada con su abogado defensor
por lo que vi en la pantalla del vídeo
ansa en su chip parecía gozar de buena
salud
las protestas contra la junta militar
que la depuso se mantienen en varias
ciudades del país a pesar de que según
organizaciones de derechos humanos más
de 500 civiles han muerto durante las
manifestaciones una cifra que no deja de
aumentar
igual que la tensión en mianmar
recientemente la presión del ejército
salió de las ciudades para dirigirse
hacia las fronteras del país donde
varios grupos étnicos armados operan
desde hace años en la frontera con
tailandia los ataques desplazaron a unas
3.000 personas de la etnia karen la
unión nacional karen que tiene una
facción armada en la región ya aseguró
que se está preparando para responder a
la ofensiva militar para defender su
territorio y otros tres grupos rebeldes
advirtieron a la junta que romperán el
alto al fuego pactado con el gobierno y
se unirán a las protestas si la
violencia contra los civiles persiste
si no se detienen y continúan matando a
la gente
cooperaremos con los manifestantes y
lucharemos así el conflicto en mianmar
se acerca cada vez más a una guerra
civil
ante el recrudecimiento de la violencia
tanto españa como eeuu pidieron a sus
ciudadanos que abandonen el territorio